hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
surely you've read these stories in the
news media about how one or another
thing you could do will
change your brain right playing angry
birds
changes your brain reading twitter
changes your brain eating captain crunch
changes your brain
it's very scary like your brain is very
precious to you all this stuff keeps
changing your brain
well it's all true of course but here's
the thing
every time you open your eyes it changes
your brain in fact forget about opening
your eyes
every bit of sensory input you get
changes your brain and probably even
without
sensory input your brain would be
changing because we call it
looking and listening and getting
memories imprinted right
the connections between our neurons are
slightly being shuffled by the imprints
that we get from the world around us
the brain is something that changes it's
not a static thing
today's guest is david eagleman who's a
neuroscientist
author and entrepreneur dave and i have
been friends for a long time done a lot
of things together
he has a new book out called live wired
the inside story of the ever-changing
brain and it's about exactly this idea
that you should rather than think of the
brain as a fixed structure where we move
around the furniture inside
the brain itself changes and there's
sort of subtle ways that happens like
when you get a new memory
but there's also deep and profound ways
that it happens and we can
use this plasticity of the brain to our
advantage
we can use it for people who are missing
sensory apparatuses right people who
can't hear who can't see
we can replace those modalities by
giving the brain
other ways to pick up signals from the
outside world the brain will rewire
itself to compensate and of course we
have a whole frontier ahead of us
in virtual reality where not only can we
seem to visit places that are very
different than the reality we live in
but we can be different things right if
you've ever been
in a in a video game or in second life
and any time when you have an
avatar the avatar doesn't need to look
like you and moreover the avatar doesn't
even need to be humanoid
interestingly the brain will rewire
itself
just a little bit to take control over
whatever
kind of shape that thing that is your
avatar in virtual reality actually has
this idea is going to become more and
more important as we break down the
barriers between the brain and the rest
of the world
through brain computer interfaces who
knows neural laces
implants and so forth so david is a
wonderful person to talk to about this
stuff he's very engaging he knows the
stuff inside and out
there's a lot of good stories here i
think this is going to be an episode you
really like
now occasional reminder that here on
mindscape we have a patreon you can
contribute to just go to patreon.com
sean m carroll the benefits are number
one
you get ad-free versions of every
episode of mindscape
number two you can ask questions at the
monthly asking anything episode
and number three and most important you
feel like you are a supporting member
of the mindscape community i think
that's what everyone wants to be and so
with that
let's go
[Music]
david eagle and welcome to the mindscape
podcast hey great to be here sean
so the brain it's very complicated i
don't know if you've noticed this it's
it's
as a simple-minded physicist this is
very hard sometimes to get wrap my brain
around the brain
yes yeah you know it's uh as you know
and just to
set context here you know it's got 86
billion neurons
neurons are the specialized cell type in
the brain and um each one of these is
connected about 10 000 of its neighbors
so you've got about 0.2 quadrillion
connections
and you have changes happening every
second of your life and all these
connections
yeah yeah and actually oh sorry just
these changes go all the way down to the
inside of the cells too and down to the
nucleus and the genome
oh okay you know somehow that that
escaped me
except it was one of the questions i
want to ask about you know
what does it mean when we say the brain
is changing i know the strength of
different connections between
the brain changes but you're telling me
that the individual
neurons change their nuclei et cetera
yeah so here's the interesting thing ai
which has been tremendously successful
has taken off from essentially a cartoon
version of the brain
which is that you have these neurons
and connections between them and so ai
says look let's just worry about
what are all the units and the strength
of the connection we adjust the strength
but in fact yeah everything is changing
in the brain you have all kinds of
levels layers of things changing from
the strength of the synapse to the fact
that the neuron itself is like a giant
tree that's
unplugging and re-plugging and seeking
and moving its branches all the time and
looking for new connections
to the number of receptors that it
distributes on the on the surface to the
biochemical cascades on the inside
all the way down to the to the genome
inside the nucleus what's called
epigenetics which is the way that it
changes the conformation of the genome
so that certain genes are
expressing more and some are getting
suppressed that sort of thing
you know i love this because we're
getting wildly off topic right away so
this is the best kind of this best kind
of podcast because you bring up ai
and i've talked with a few people in the
ai world and will continue to do so
and you just said ai has been
tremendously successful but
that depends on what your standards are
right i mean
uh especially in deep learning neural
net kind of
kind of work that we throw a bunch of
data at a system
and it picks out some patterns and
learns on the basis of that but
when i've talked to people on the
podcast like stuart russell
melanie mitchell a couple things come
through one is the
difficulty in teaching ai systems common
sense
and another one is you know the brain
isn't just big with
86 billion neurons but it's it's
structured right i mean there are layers
and sub
uh organizational pieces that that exist
in a hierarchy
and ai doesn't have anything uh
ai doesn't quite function the same way
in many of his most successful
implementations so
while i have you here on the podcast uh
do you think
that we we should be taking more literal
lessons from the brain
when we think about ai oh of course yeah
i mean ai
is is so distant the way i see it is
it's like a fork in the road or a fork
in code
where you've got um yeah i haven't gone
off in one direction and when i say
tremendously successful i mean
it can do things like distinguish
photographs of cats from dogs with
superhuman performance
but it can't do anything that a
three-year-old kid can do like walk into
a room
decide where to go next navigate a
complex uh set of obstacles
put food in her mouth manipulate adults
you know all the things that a kid can
do
so it turns out that um yeah the way
that we've gone off with ai
uh can do great things but it is nothing
like the brain and we have
so much uh more ahead of us in
neuroscience that will eventually
inspire ai
and make it a lot better okay good i
mean it's probably both ways right i
mean
we can be hamstrung by thinking too much
about the brain when we do ai and then
we can
miss chances to take advantage of things
we learned about the brain
yeah well i think the whole key is
figuring out what are the principles
that the brain is implementing there's
obviously tons of detail but
what is actually happening in the brain
yeah like what's yeah uh you know like
if you were looking at
the nucleus hundred years ago
and you might say gosh there are
millions of proteins around here and
it's infinitely complicated but then
crick and watson come along and say hey
you know it's about keeping the order of
the base pairs and everything else is
detail
that's the kind of stuff that we need
for the brain
and that's that's actually what i've
endeavored to do in my book live wired
is try to
figure out what are the principles
what's happening here
with this system that is not anything
like hardware
or software but it's this entirely other
thing which
of course i call livewear which is doing
something very different than what we
typically do
in silicon valley yeah and i think that
uh i mean the great thing about your new
book is how much it emphasizes the
changeability of the brain
you know i'm always amused by these
stories that say like
uh playing video games changes your
brain and you're like well
so does opening your eyes change your
brain in some way so that's not a very
fascinating thing but
before we get there i want to give you a
chance again once i have you here
because you've written other books and
and one of the
lessons i took from other things you've
done is the
sort of the the unimportance
of our rational cognitive brain to much
of what goes on right i mean
the brain is uh hierarchical
there are layers there are many little
modules going on and maybe this will be
important later on
tell us a little bit about how you know
our conscious brains are just sort of
riding on top of
a whole bunch of things going on beneath
the surface yeah
the conscious part of you is like a
broom closet in the mansion
of the brain and almost everything going
on
you don't have access to and you don't
even have awareness of of course so
um an analogy that i used in my book
incognito was like
we are it's like you you are a stowaway
on a transatlantic steam ship and you're
taking
credit for the whole journey without
acknowledging all the machinery under
foot
so our brains are up to
enormously complicated stuff just the
fact that each one of these neurons
is popping off between you know tens and
hundreds of times a second as in you
know sending these little zeros and ones
around
and you've got these you know the
unbelievable number of spikes happening
in your head in any one second if each
of these translated to a photon of light
it would be blinding to you and um but
you don't have access to that all you
know is
oh i feel hungry or whatever the thing
is or
or what happens when you when you think
oh i just had an idea right
it wasn't you that had the idea exactly
it was your brain's been working on that
for days or weeks behind the scenes
evaluating
hypotheses comparing things trying
things out
simulating possible futures and so on
eventually it serves it up to your
conscious mind and you say oh i'm a
genius i just thought of something but
we're sort of the last guy on the ladder
to get any information
well i think probably that's something
that we can easily swallow when it comes
to
you know the fact that we get through
the day so easily you know
if you drive to work you often are not
even conscious of the decisions you're
making right or
uh most people don't know how to walk if
you ask them you know explicitly
how to move their limbs but but it works
but what about when we're explicitly
being conscious like if we're
using using our cognitive capacities uh
to try to be rational is there should we
be a little bit more
skeptical of our abilities to be
rational under those circumstances
i mean in general that's always worthy
of skepticism because um
i mean we've all had the experience of
thinking okay i've thought through this
problem i've got it exactly right i know
exactly
all that this logically fits and then
you find out at some point oh actually i
can't believe i overlooked that how did
i not see that
so this happens to us all the time so we
shouldn't take anything too seriously
about our own
um cognition or our belief that
something is right
um and of course you know people end up
for example with mental illness people
believe that they
have the right story about something and
and
it turns out no one else agrees with
them um and
yeah what's weird is we're all trapped
on our own
planet essentially you know i saw this i
saw this movie poster
uh for the martian with matt damon and
he's standing all by himself on the red
planet
and i thought wow that's just a perfect
analogy for what it's like to be
a human you've got this inner
cosmos of your brain you've got yours
i've got mine everyone's got theirs
and we believe everything to be right
and self-consistent
in our on our planet um but then of
course i mean especially now you just
you talk to other people
who have different political opinions
than you do on social media
and and each one of us thinks wow i know
that i'm right and i'm the default human
being
and they must be crazy or aggressive or
trolling or whatever you just can't
believe that anyone has a different
opinion than you do well actually that's
exactly the metaphor i used in my book
the big picture i call them planets of
belief
and uh different people have different
pieces that fit together very nicely on
their planets but they might be very
incompatible with someone else
awesome wow that's great trying to
influence the social psychology
literature
let's see how how far i can get there
but okay i mean
um and this is sort of an entryway
into the fact that you know the brain is
modular it
comes in pieces and we're going to get
to how it changes and things like that
but
i'm worried by the computer metaphor a
little bit right i mean in some sense we
understand computers a lot
better than we understand the brain and
i think that it's it's
very tempting for people to think of
their brains like a little
laptop computer but there are ways in
which that's just a bad idea right
exactly right i mean one thing is the
the word memory it turns out that memory
is so different in computers than it is
in a human brain in a computer you're
storing a little file of some sort
and that's an exact replica of what's
happened but
of course you know if i tell you a joke
you don't remember
phoneme by phoneme exactly what i said
like in audio recording instead you
could turn around and if you speak
another language you can tell someone
else in another language right away
because it's the gist of the joke that
you've gotten and of course the gist of
it has to do with
every one of your experiences leading up
to this moment what that joke means
to you and your on your planet so
um uh right that's one thing but
but this is also why i introduced the
term livewear
to distinguish it from hardware and
software because often people when
they're talking about the brain
sort of make that mistake of using those
terms because we're so used to them but
of course you know here in silicon
valley an engineer is
given kudos for making clean trim
efficient hardware and a software layer
that that's on top of that but what's
happening in the brain is totally
different because
every time activity passes through the
brain it is
actually changing the structure yeah and
it's not just changing the structure
it's doing
so or at least this is what i propose a
whole framework for thinking about this
in the book it changes it at all these
different time scales
so you've got certain things in the
brain that are changing rapidly
all the way to things that are changing
slowly um and this has to do with
different
areas of the brain and different layers
and and the stuff that i mentioned
before about synapses biochemical
cascades all the way down to the
changing of the genetic expression
so essentially each layer is looking at
the one above it and saying
sorry each time layer i'm talking about
it's looking at the one above it and
saying
look do i believe the data is that
actually stable enough that i'm gonna
make a change
okay yeah i believe that i'm seeing that
over and over i'll go ahead and make a
change and then the next
time layer says okay well i'm a little
more conservative so i'm going to wait
and see
but but so there's things that are
changing all over the brain
all different time scales all the time
good in physics we'd call that the
renormalization group
so there's a lot of a lot of
similarities there uh but
but maybe um we can dig into these
layers and modularity a bit more i mean
i think that
uh the computer metaphor is not the only
one that gets in the way we also have
when it comes to
any living organism we have this sort of
metaphor that the dna is a blueprint
and you just sort of print out what it's
like but
one of the points you make is that the
different parts of the brain
change their responsibilities uh in
response to various things that are
happening but clearly
there's some some structure there in the
dna
telling us what to do i mean what
they're telling the different parts of
the brain what to do
what is the balance between how much is
pre-programmed and how much we pick up
along the way
yeah you know it's interesting because
you and i are both old enough that we
remember when the year 2000
came along and and the human genome
project
came to fruition and it was a very
exciting time because
it was all gonna be written down all the
the instructions for putting together a
human
including the brain and uh and as it
turns out
it was it was disappointing in a sense
scientifically speaking because
it really didn't tell us too much i mean
it's super important work and i'm glad
we have it but
the argument i make in the book is that
the other half of what wires up your
brain
you will never be written down in a book
because it's everything all around us
it's all of your experiences everything
that's happened to you every
conversation you've had every friend
you've had your parents all that stuff
um you know more broadly your culture
and your society
so um there's this old question in
biology of course about nature versus
nurture and
i think it's pretty much understood at
this point that it's completely a dead
question nature versus nurture because
it's always both
because these things interact with one
another
meaning you come to the table with a
certain
genome and these are sort of your
starting instructions that start the
dominoes kicking over
and then every experience you have from
the moment you pop out of the womb
is changing the structure of your brain
and that
can feed all the way back to your
genetic expression so these things
become very tightly intertwined
um from the get-go the way i think about
it i guess the way a
physicist would think about it is sort
of a you know this uh
like a space-time cone where you
are given where your starting point of
the genetics you can go off on all these
different trajectories but you're sort
of bounded
yeah presumably by the genetics you come
to the table with for example i could
never be a swimmer like
michael phelps because i just don't have
the wingspan he has
so you're bounded somehow by your
genetics but within that there's a lot
of space where you might go depending on
your experiences
if you're a lifelong learner i can
highly recommend checking out the great
courses plus the great courses plus is a
streaming service that offers
unlimited learning at a time when we
need it the most you get access to a
wide variety of courses from the great
courses in all sorts of different topics
i'm a great courses professor myself and
i know from the process
of doing it how much care and effort
they put into
making sure the right people give those
courses and that they're recorded with
the highest standards of professionalism
one fun course i've noticed is unlocking
the hidden history
of dna so this course teaches you not
only
what dna is what we've learned about it
but how we've put that knowledge
to use you can get interesting insights
into the secret past of historical
figures from
king tut to genghis khan and the great
courses app makes it easy learn it
anytime
anywhere in the world it's a perfect
gift as well as a perfect gift to
yourself so visit my special url today
the greatcoursesplus.com mindscape
and you can treat yourself to a free
trial of access to the entire library
so don't wait sign up now at th e great
courses plus dot com slash mindscape
you do make you do have some vivid
examples
in the book of the importance of this
process by which the brain becomes wired
dynamically during childhood
because there are unfortunate examples
where it didn't happen right where
someone was just completely deprived of
the ordinary
context and stimuli that the rest of us
get
that's exactly right yeah this is these
are some of nature's tragic experiments
where
you have a child who's so badly
neglected that
you know here's the way to think about
it is that mother nature
has figured out this thing with humans
especially
where we are the most plastic species
around and by you know by plastic i mean
uh
you know flexible modifiable on the fly
and
um so what mother nature figured is hey
you know instead of trying to
wire everything up from the get-go i'm
just going to drop this animal in
to the world half-baked and let the
environment wire this animal up and
that's turned out to be an unbelievably
successful strategy and we've taken over
every corner of the planet and invented
all kinds of
great stuff like podcasts and so on and
what we
uh but but it's a gamble it's a gamble
because what what you have to assume is
that a child is going to get the right
kind of input and there's a pretty broad
definition of what the right kind of
input would be but at minimum that
includes love and touch and
language and that kind of stuff and so
occasionally you'll find
these kids who are so severely neglected
that they didn't get
the right kind of inputs and their
windows of plasticity close and then
they are unable to learn
things like language or even how to chew
food or how to interact socially
and um a couple of the cases i discussed
in the book
you know these children were found by
like let's say the age of 11 or 13
but it was it's too late for their brain
it's it's at a point where it can't um
figure out how to do it correctly
anymore which is a pretty killer
argument against the pure
uh nature idea right i mean pure nurture
idea also doesn't fly but
you need some upbringing at the right
crucial time
yes exactly right yeah and this is uh
you know as i
as i said this the strategy of saying
look let's just drop
into the world half baked means that we
have these extraordinarily long
infancies much longer than any other
animal
but boy it really pays off because what
a kid can do
is go and figure out what other humans
have learned before him or her
and then springboard off that as opposed
to if you're you know
a goat you're born and you have to learn
how to be a goat again in every
generation
um they don't have goat school and go
libraries and so on to
go internet to jump to jump to the next
level
wikipedia yeah but i mean is there a way
to
quantify or or or test this idea that we
are the most flexible in some way it
seems plausible to me
but what does it mean yeah um so
just as an example i just published
paper comparing 25 species of primates
and you can look at all kinds of things
like how long do
how long does it take before they wean
from their mothers how long before they
learn how to walk
how long before they reach adolescence
there are all kinds of measures like
this which at least are good
um proxies for plasticity
um that tell you essentially how much an
animal is you know
coming to the table prepared or
unprepared you know pre-programmed or
not
and then at the cellular level there are
all kinds of measures you can take about
how
how flexible the the neurons are in the
networks of neurons as opposed to how
pre-pre-baked the whole system comes and
i love the examples you have in the book
about where you know we do have in our
brains
different parts different physical
locations in the brain that are
uh dedicated to certain purposes right
you know occipital lobe or whatever
auditory cortex and uh maybe it's not a
cortex i don't know
but um but they they if something
happens where you go blind or something
like that that part of the brain just
doesn't waste away or die
it it gets repurposed which is kind of
amazing
yeah exactly i mean the main lesson i
would say that's come out of
neuroscience
um on this topic is that no real estate
ever sits unused
no land lies fallow instead it gets
taken over so if
if a child is born blind the part of the
brain that we would normally call the
visual cortex
is no longer visual now it's doing other
things doing hearing and touch
and so on and you know if you're born
deaf you're auditory cortex in quotes
does not
it's no longer auditory cortex it takes
over it gets taken over by other
functions one of the things i mentioned
in the book
that's always just stunned me is um
there's a type of surgery called the
hemispherectomy which is when a child
has really bad epilepsy on one side of
their brain
and they go in for this surgery where
half of their brain is removed
and it turns out as long as you do it
when the kid is young let's say before
six or seven
the child is just fine and the reason is
the remaining half just sort of rewires
um taking over any functions that were
on the missing half and and it does that
and occasionally you'll find a child who
is only born with one hemisphere
and and the way that the rewiring
happens is just stunning where the child
often will there'll really be no clues
no cognitive clues that this child only
has
half of a brain so yeah it's an
extraordinarily flexible system
and so um yeah what this means by the
way just as a side note
is that for someone who let's say is
blind
they actually provably have better
hearing and better touch because they
just devote more real estate
towards those other functions and the
more you have the better normally a
brain
is busy sharing the real estate with all
these different tasks but
if you're doing a lot of it to one thing
you can be quite great at it
and what's amazing to me is that
obviously there
is some genetic predisposition to put
different functions in different parts
of the brain like our
visual cortex is in the same location in
everybody
but it can also be completely rewired
under the right circumstances so
clearly there's some give and take there
exactly well
the only reason that it's the same place
in everybody is because what you have
what the genetics determine
are these very basic instructions about
okay take these fibers from the eye
and plug them into this part of the
thalamus called the lateral junicular
nucleus
and then from there take neurons and
plug those into
the back of the head and the occipital
cortex
that's what the instructions give you
therefore
data from the eyeballs comes in and
ends up making its way to the to the
back of the head and so that becomes
what we call visual cortex but
yeah in 2000 a group at mit did an
experiment where they
took the data from the eyeballs and they
re-rooted it
so that it went to a different part of
the brain in this case what would have
normally been the auditory cortex this
was in ferrets of course not humans
but um and uh and what happened is that
part of the
brain what they would have thought of as
the auditory cortex now became visual
cortex it had all the properties visual
cortex
and it behaved like it the animal could
do all kinds of visual tasks with it and
so
what this brings home for us is the fact
that when you look at the cortex which
is you know the wrinkly
pink outside bit about three millimeters
in thickness on the outside of the brain
um everywhere you look it looks the same
in terms of for example the cellular
architecture it's the same
and that's because it is the same it's
the same stuff and it's just a matter of
what data cable you're plugging into it
if you're plugging in a visual data
cable then it becomes visual cortex
auditory and so on so that was gonna be
my next question the actual individual
neurons in the auditory cortex are
essentially indistinguishable from those
in the visual cortex is that right
exactly right if i showed you in fact if
i opened up
a hole in somebody's skull
and i let's say had a magical microscope
that could look at all the activity and
all the neurons underneath that opening
and i said to you sean what part of the
brain are we looking at is that visual
or auditory or somatosensory
you would have no idea and i would have
no idea as a professional neuroscientist
because it's exactly the same stuff it's
just spikes it's these
little electrical signals and you have
these chemical signals to to carry
information from one neuron to the other
looks exactly the same everywhere no
matter where in the cortex you look
and the not having half a brain is
obviously a dramatic example of this but
maybe more um not more provocatively but
more usefully
uh when people lose limbs or something
like that
uh or when people gain extra
sensory things uh they can rewire the
brain or the brain be wires itself i
suppose is a better way of saying it to
adapt to that new kind of body that they
have
yeah exactly i mean one of the one of
the stories i tell in the book is just
that
in the 1960s a neuroscientist named
wilder penfield was the first to
discover that if you stick
recording electrodes into the brain you
find that
there's a map of the body in the brain
so
it's as though your brain knows that you
have arms and fingers and legs and toes
and
everything and and um and everyone
thought wow this is amazing it must be
genetically pre-specified but it turns
out it is not
because if you for example lose an arm
your map of your body and your brain
will change so that it represents a map
a body that does not have an arm and
so what this tells us is that it's
activity dependent and depending on the
information streaming up into the brain
the brain changes its map of what's
going on now you know the thing to
remember of course as an introductory
way of thinking about this is that
your brain is locked in silence and
darkness it's just this three pound
mission control center
it has no idea what your body is
supposed to look like
one of the stories i tell because i
because i just love this so much as
there's this dog
named faith who was born without front
legs and so faith just walks bipedally
on her back legs
and uh and it's stunning to watch her
um and the question is you know could
any dog walk on their back legs
probably but they don't have the
sufficient motivation to do it but
but but she had to get to food and water
and her mother and so on so she just
walks on her back legs but the point
is you look at faith and it's clear that
the dog
brain is not pre-programmed to drive the
dog body
brains are just programmed to figure out
what are their capabilities to figure
out what are the affordances that they
have in the world
and and then adjust accordingly so that
it can drive the machinery
and clearly we have some experience with
losing
limbs and adjusting uh appropriately and
but increasingly we're gaining limbs
back right i mean that we're getting
prosthetic limbs and can the brain
rewire itself to think of a prosthetic
limb as part of our body
oh exactly and it turns out that you can
do things like for somebody who's
totally paralyzed
you can put an electrode array in their
motor cortex and then hook that up
and have them control a robotic arm and
um and this is of course very useful for
somebody whose body is paralyzed
the engineers have to make a lot of
tweaks to try to make their algorithm
better but really
most of the work is just for the person
themselves to
to learn flexibly how to think about it
to move the arm how to think
just right to make the fingers move
subtly and grasp this and so on
and um and and in monkeys there are
experiments where
the monkey can use let's say both his
arms and
a third robotic arm and they can
function just fine that way
and of course these are the expensive
ways of doing it but the cheap way of
doing it is with vr where you can hook
up a
vr game where let's say you're
controlling a third arm so one of my
colleagues here at stanford jeremy
baillinson has this game where
you're holding two controllers you are
with those controlling your two arms in
virtual reality
and then you're also you also have a
third arm coming out of your chest
and by turning the controllers by
turning your wrists
um you're controlling the third arm and
what you're trying to do is grab as many
boxes
as possible in as short a time and so it
turns out the way to do this is to use
the third arm
and it only takes about three minutes
for people to get really
good at it and and of course there's a
sense in which
we know how flexible our body plan is
because when you jump on a bicycle
you know evolution never saw wheels
coming but it's just not that hard for
you to figure out how to use that or a
pogo stick or a hang glider or anything
like that you are
that becomes part of your body um
i've heard the famous story of the
virtual reality lobster that i guess
jerome lanier uh did where some people
at least some people sometimes
can learn to control all eight legs of a
lobster in virtual reality independently
yeah
exactly you know what's funny i tried
looking that up and i couldn't find any
detailed information on that so i just
mentioned it as the story that inspired
other vr guys to
to try you know quantifying this well
but
in a case like that um can you actually
see changes in the brain does like does
the little homunculus the map of our
body and our brains
become different uh if we lose a limb or
if we're in vr
so so to my knowledge no one has
combined this vr
with fmri with brain imaging but
it has to be true i mean it just has to
be true but in the same way that there
are changes in your brain when you learn
how to ride a bicycle or
um you know or one of the things i
mentioned in the book is this
uh guy dustin sandlin who who got from
his friend
a backwards bicycle so so when you turn
the handlebar to the left it turns the
wheel to the right and vice versa
and so you know it took him a month to
get good at it but then he's able to
ride a backwards bicycle and he can jump
on different bikes and ride them both
um of course there are changes in the
brain to my knowledge
no one's done fmri on him uh with those
bikes but
that's how everything is stored is by
changes in the structure of the brain
i guess that makes sense but it it
highlights a question i hadn't even
realized that i had
which is seemingly there are changes in
the brain and then there are changes in
the brain right i mean maybe this is a
uh remnant of the bad computer
metaphor where we think of the computer
as having certain hardwired things and
then we have software that we can
download and so
forth so no one is surprised that i can
learn
to do things that that's fine in some
weak sense that's a change in the brain
but is
is that all there is or is there a
stronger sense of
the image that i have of myself in my
brain is literally different
it's interesting that you're uh that
your intuition is to you think of it in
a weak sense in a strong sense because
that's all anything is i mean it's all
just changes in the brain so when you
um sean i can't remember how long ago
you and i met probably at least a decade
ago but
when you met me and learned that my name
was david and what my face looked like
that is represented by changes in your
brain right
that is synchronized over literally
millions or hundreds of millions of
synapses the connections between neurons
and all the way down to biochemical
cascades and receptors and so on
and of course i could never know how
exactly i am represented in your brain
uh in the in detail but but i'm
represented
in the context of other people you've
met
and maybe i looked a little bit like
your friend from the 8th grade
and a little bit of this thing whatever
the the details are
it orchestrated massive changes in the
structure of your brain and that's what
it means to remember
anything any fact even the fact that we
were meeting online today at 3
30 you have to store that you have to
yeah everything is about changes at the
synaptic level at the biochemical
cascade level
sometimes all the way down to the genes
on the internet you can go just about
anywhere the problem is
people might be looking at where you're
going whether it's your internet service
provider
or hackers or snoopers or whatever what
you want is a bit more privacy
in the form of a vpn a virtual private
network
and private internet access pia can
provide
exactly that pia is a very simple system
to use
you can download it very easily and one
subscription will protect up to 10
different devices at the same time
once you've installed pia all of your
web traffic
goes through a secure vpn tunnel so your
ip address is hidden and all of your
data is encrypted
you'll get a 30-day money-back guarantee
if you sign up at our mindscape listener
special url
private internet access dot com slash
mindscape
by using this link you get complete
digital privacy for less than three
dollars a month
and you get three extra months for free
that's
private internet access dot com slash
mindscape
surf more securely today
okay this goes back to the conversation
we started with with the neurons
firing i mean i i still want to say
there's a there's a structure in the
brain in the sense that
certain neurons fire when the action
potentials
do the right thing when they're getting
the right input but then there's also
physical connections between the neurons
right i mean
are both of those changing in different
ways or is that all kind of the same
mush going on it's the same mush going
on what's often
thought about i would say all the
attention is on the connection the
synapses
between neurons because what we know is
that those can get
stronger or weaker when we do particular
experimental manipulations we can see oh
look that's gotten stronger it's gotten
weaker
but um you know i just want to
re-emphasize this thing that
it's it's not only that it's that the
shape of the neuron itself
is changing what's happening just past
the synapse with the
number of receptors that are there to
capture the neurotransmitter
the chemicals that are released that
changes the distribution of those
receptors the number of receptors
the um the biochemical cascades that
those lead to
all the way down to the nucleus of the
cell all of that's changing at once
right and but but i'm going to just
stubbornly try to
it sounds like i'm being stubborn
disagreeing with you what i'm actually
trying to do is is
sweep out all of my misconceptions here
um there's a sense in which i learn
something at a surface level
uh like i'm told you know how to read
music and if i sit there and think about
it i can see
a different note on the staff
corresponds to a certain pitch etcetera
but then if i do it enough it becomes
automatic
and it's it's certain i've learned it at
a certain deeper
level is there once again a physical
structural
difference between those two kinds of
learning or is everything just a
combination
of all these things going on at once
well no i mean there are structural
differences so first if i tell you
something that you're just holding in
working memory
let's say not something like reading
music but i just tell you um
some some translation in chinese some
word yeah and so
uh i told you that spider is jiju so you
can sort of remember that and hold it in
working memory
um but it's not really going any deeper
than that and that's just the activity
in your brain but
for it to actually get cemented into the
structure
there are various things you can do to
practice that maybe say it out loud
maybe tell someone else that's what the
word is and so on
um but this goes back there's actually
two things this goes back to one is this
issue that we
mentioned before about the different
time scales of change so
um you know something that you hear once
and maybe learning the word for spider
in chinese means absolutely nothing to
you and so
it doesn't really have relevance so it
doesn't ever stick at the deeper levels
by deeper i mean um more conservative
the renormalization group issue
yeah so um so there's that
the second thing i want to mention
there's actually several points second
thing i want to mention is that
when you're learning something like
sheet music it starts off
as a purely conscious issue like take
riding a bike
when you first tried that as a child
it was all about oh i'm having to pay so
much attention to this and i'm like
how do i turn my torso and blah blah but
eventually it becomes completely
unconscious to you and that's because
you're actually burning it down into the
circuitry so if you look at the
activity in the brain of somebody just
starting to learn a bike versus the
activity of
a professional bicyclist you see that
the latter case there's almost no
activity in the brain why because it's
been burnt into the part of the
circuitry
for for speed and efficiency and so in
the first case it's all
conscious and you're having to think
through all the possibilities
and in the second case it's just really
deep uh into the circuitry
that's interesting the fact that there
is less activity
in the brain when an expert is doing
something than when
a novice is doing something yeah it's
very counter-intuitive but the first
experiments on this were done with the
video game tetris
where it was amateurs versus
professionals and the professionals
brain isn't doing much of anything and
yeah and it's counterintuitive in a
sense but it's because the whole reason
the brain is changing
is for the purpose of speed and
efficiency
so if you can turn something into the
physical structure of the circuitry boy
that makes it really
fast and efficient let me see just one
more thing the third thing i want to say
about change in the brain is that this
is also
you one can't ignore the issue of
relevance to the organism so
if i tell you some you know whatever
some word in chinese that just
really doesn't mean anything to you and
uh you couldn't care less
you don't have the right cocktail of
neurotransmitters present
to make any change but if um
but if i tell you something that's
really really important to you and your
career
and your survival or whatever it is
that's really going to stick
because the right neurotransmitters are
there that says wow this
is a piece of information i need that
matters for me
and i guess that's one aspect of
something you already mentioned i didn't
want to quite let go which is that
even when you are even when two people
are learning something
the same thing it's a different thing
happening
in each of their brains like you said
when i see a new person and i recognize
them i recognize them by relating them
to other things in my brain
which means that the fantasy in the
matrix of just downloading
how to fly a helicopter or how to do
kung fu isn't how it's going to work
exactly right because the way that you
would
fly a b212 helicopter and the way that i
would
is is different so you know you might
think of it in terms of oh yeah it's
just like a motorcycle and lean it this
way now i might think of it in terms of
oh it's like a horse when i'm on a horse
and i pull this way and pull that way
um of course i'm not even talking
consciously i'm talking about all the
stuff about how it is getting encoded in
the brain
uh exactly so so you know i mentioned
that this
i mentioned in the book that the thing
about the matrix isn't
plausible that you could just download
something in somebody's brain but there
is i think a
way that we can think about that which
is you'd have to do a very thorough
system identification first which is to
say
if i could actually understand
your brain and everything about the way
it's working then maybe i could download
the instructions for how to fly that
helicopter
but i'd have to really do a lot of work
to understand your brain first
well wouldn't i have to be you i mean in
some sense
my way of knowing how to fly a
helicopter is different than your way of
knowing it
oh totally there are different ways but
if i could do system identification on
you i mean this is pure fantasy but
maybe a thousand years we'll have this
where
essentially i present to your brain
500 000 different scenarios
i present this and i'm looking at the
activity in your brain in response to
each
enough that i have a pretty good sense
of what your brain as an individual
brain
is up to and then i say okay so here's
how i would add helicopter flying on top
of that
[Music]
maybe i mean people want to do that
right people want to upload their brains
uh
and i'm always i'm not skeptical about
this at a philosophical level because
i'm a substrate independence of
consciousness kind of guy like it's all
just
uh physical particles representing
information in motion but
i think that people still are beholden
to this metaphor that the information in
their brain is like a big
file on a computer that they can use a
usb
connection to just download and run it
on some other hardware and it will work
perfectly well but
it's more complex than that not only
within the brain and the neurons talking
to each other but with all of the
sensory input and and motor output that
is involved yeah now that's interesting
because
in theory if we could replicate
all of the important pieces and parts
which is probably almost certainly much
more than just the neurons and their
connections which is how ai folks think
about it nowadays but
if you could actually replicate all the
important stuff and of course we don't
know exactly which details are the
important parts but
um if you're a substrate independent guy
then you
should be able to upload your brain you
have
all the stuff about your your body and
of course all the organs in your body
like your adrenal gland
all these other things that are sending
hormones and information
to your brain but all that stuff could
be summarized pretty easily
like in a one meg file probably and so
the the the brain itself those three
pounds that's the densest representation
of you
and then it's just trying to figure out
you know what are its capabilities in
the world and when it puts
information out what does it get back
and so on but i suspect it just
i mean look we'll both be dead before uh
either of us can you know hold each
other to to a bet that we make on this
but
i don't know i really don't think it's
more than 75 years or something before
we've got
essentially uploading um where we say
okay look here's all the important
pieces and parts that we need to capture
for you and
the secret nightmare scenario is we have
i like the idea that it's just a one meg
file that is keeping all of our you know
simple chemical influences that are
affecting our brain
so for instance we become hungry we
become tired right uh
and maybe this is crucially important to
how we
function in the real world but maybe
it's not a lot of information maybe
that's the easy part
to put up into the matrix but then once
we're there we go oh you know what um
now i can control everything now i'm
just gonna change the dial so i don't
get hungry so i don't get tired
and then you realize that there's no
reason to keep living because we've got
rid of all of our motivations and we
realized that
life was all just you know a weird thing
that we were going through and then we
turn everything off
oh i certainly i certainly agree i mean
you can't enjoy the
the good moments without the contrast of
the bad moments
it's tricky so yeah what you'd want to
do is
have somebody have a company upload you
but you don't get control of the
dashboard oh yeah no i don't want that
at all are you kidding me
i don't want anyone else to have control
over my dashboard so that's that's the
dilemma that i'm in but anyway like you
said
further out than uh each of our
individual lifespans unless they you
know
cure immortality first that's always
possible yes let's hope
there's something else you mentioned
that i don't want to quite get let uh
go which is the monkey with the third
arm um uh
given everything you've already said
sure i can believe
that um the brain is flexible enough
to adapt to a circumstance where i have
not just replaced
limbs and things like that but i have
new ones so i'm like i'm a different
kind of cyborg
being but there still needs to be some
way
now we're in the real world not in
fantasy world there needs to be some way
for me to get the neural impulses
to these extra limbs i mean do people
think about this in a in a
realistic way about how to actually give
ourselves capabilities we don't already
have and wire it successfully to the
brain
yeah exactly so when it comes to motor
output
the way they do this with the monkey is
they just put an electrode an array of
electrodes
into the motor cortex and what what all
these systems are very good at in the
brain is
is flexibility so they say okay look
this part here is controlling
one arm this part's controlling another
arm oh but i see i have a third arm so
that's cool i'll just share some of this
real estate some of what these neurons
are doing so that now they're
controlling this arm and of course the
monkey can see
what the robotic arm is doing and so
that's the input so you've got the
output of what's getting caused in the
input
and essentially what you have is motor
babbling which is where you know the
monkey tries
things and sees what's going on and
eventually gets better and better at it
just the way that a baby
babbles with language and compares that
to what their
mother and father are saying and they
get better and better at articulating
um and so when it comes to motor output
yeah it's easy enough you just hook up
something and you get the
the feedback and then of course um
what i've been working on for the last
decade is what would it be like to add
new
senses could we add a new sense so you
know we've got our eyes and our ears and
our
nose and now and and we're used to these
things and we think of them as
fundamental but in fact it's just what
we happen to have inherited from a long
road of evolution
and you know your eyes are just turning
photons into
electrochemical spikes your ears are
turning air compression waves into
electrochemical spikes your nose is
turning mixtures of molecules into
spikes and so on
and it's all the same currency on the
inside
and so this got me thinking hard
yeah starting about 10 years ago about
whether we could just add a new
sense and of course it's very difficult
to imagine what a new sense
would would feel like or look like it's
as difficult as trying to
imagine a new color you just can't do it
but so what we did in my lab is we built
a
i know you know this sean but we built a
vest with vibratory motors all over it
and
we can feed in any kind of new data
stream and people can come to understand
that so just as a quick example
um what we've done by the way is shrunk
this down to a wristband
we've actually spun a company out of my
lab called neosensory and we have this
wristband called buzz
and it's got these vibratory motors on
it and so for people who are
deaf for example we capture sound in
real time and turn it into patterns of
vibration on the skin
with this little wristband and they can
come to hear the world they come to
understand what is happening in the
auditory world just based on the
vibration on their skin
because it turns out it doesn't matter
how the information gets to the brain as
long as it gets there
the brain figures out what to do with it
how to use it well that's
yeah i mean this is a crucial thing
maybe i'll just ask you to say the same
thing over again but in different words
because it's so
important i think to the future of this
that forgetting about new senses for the
moment but even with the senses we have
we can learn to
sense them in different ways so this
seems to me
to open up great vistas of opportunity
for people who have uh lost uh one or
another senses
that's exactly right and so i mean just
as one other example of what we're doing
for people
who have lost a leg and they get a
prosthetic limb
um it's actually very difficult to learn
how to walk with a prosthetic limb
because you have to look at it to see
where it is where it's swinging
when it's setting down and so on because
you don't have any feedback from it so
we put
pressure and angle sensors in it and
then give that information
through the wristband and people can
come to walk that way again because they
they're getting the information it's not
coming from the leg it's now coming
through the wrist but it doesn't matter
the brain says oh i got it these are
correlated that's what the brain's
really good at doing is figuring out
correlations between things between for
example what it's seeing and what it's
feeling
yeah we've done this with blindness so
people who are blind we
uh we did this with the vest um
and we did this over at google's offices
where they have lidar set up
and so they know the location of
everything in the office so we just
brought in blind participants
and fed them that data stream turned
into patterns of vibration on their skin
so they could tell oh there's someone
off to my left and they're coming closer
and closer because the vibration's
getting more intense
oh now the person has changed direction
now they're going behind me and i can
feel
them all the way around behind me and so
on um
and in a sense this is better than the
vision we come to the table with because
you can't see behind you and um you
can't know exactly
when you know it's like it's like being
jedi or something and knowing when
someone's approaching you from behind
so yeah these are ways of of putting in
auditory or somatosensory or visual
information into somebody
through a different channel the brain
has no problem figuring that out
i think this is what sounds so
remarkable because just like in the vr
example where we could imagine having
multiple limbs and moving them around
for the replacing vision or sound or
whatever examples we have
a mental image for what that would look
like but some of the constraints that
are there
in the typical biological circumstances
need not be there anymore so it's kind
of hard to
visualize if you will what it would be
like to
see 360 degrees all around us
right exactly so you know actually in in
live wired i i take a few pages just to
discuss this issue about
how impossible it is to understand
someone else's
internal experience so for example if
you've ever had a
friend who is born blind you can try to
explain
vision to her all day long but she's
never going to get it it just doesn't
make any sense or if you have a friend
who's colorblind you try to explain
the color green to that person they
cannot possibly understand it and the
same thing applies here
which is that if you create a new sense
like infrared
vision or um you know feeling the
invisible states of your body like your
microbiome
and your blood pressure and so on or
feeling the stock market or twitter or
whatever you're doing
it's it's totally impossible for someone
who hasn't experienced it to understand
what it feels like because it's not like
touch or taste or hearing or smell it's
something else it's something else that
you're experiencing
you're getting dangerously close to the
discourse around mary the color
scientist right you know this one
i do of yeah
i mean we can actually basically do the
experiment for those who
who don't know it i talked about this
with philip gough and with david
chalmers you know the idea of
a scientist who was completely uh
prevented from seeing color
and the question is when she sees color
for the first time does she learn
anything new given that
even though she couldn't see color
herself she was a scientist who
understood color at the physical level
and this is supposed to be an argument
in favor of there is more to life than
just the physical structure of the brain
and i don't think many people believe
this argument but maybe
uh the this new way of thinking about
things changes it somehow
yeah that's interesting i mean i think
what everybody does get about the
argument though is that
um yeah knowing everything about it
wouldn't be the same as
experiencing the color orange in the
same way that if i explain to you
everything all the biochemical
mechanisms of why chocolate ice cream
you know what chocolate ice cream does
it's a molecule of a certain shape and
it binds certain receptors
it has actually no influence on your
experience your enjoyment of chocolate
ice cream
it makes it better or worse because the
argument's supposed to be that
therefore there is some kind of
knowledge
called what it is like to experience
something that does not get reduced
to the firing of neurons in your brain
yeah it seems like it's an emergent
property qualia is qualia is the
the internal experience of something
right and
we can talk about it you know in the
same way that
right i can explain to you all about
transistors and electricity running
through
these and resistors and so on but that
doesn't tell you why you find this
particular youtube
video funny um yeah
there's something that's missing that
you need at this higher level
so what are the new senses that we
should uh look forward to downloading
from your website someday like
you know we can fix the senses we
already have but
clearly other uh
wavelengths in the electromagnetic
spectra would be good but is there like
a completely new sense
that we could imagine yeah so um
right so we just had uh our so we've
been working
we've got probably 20 different projects
of different senses
uh underway but we just had a developer
contest and we had 70 entries to that
which was great
from all around the world where people
said look i'm going to use the buzz
and build this kind of sensor that so we
had things from let's say
you know different ways of doing
navigation directions which is super
cool but
but to things like how do you detect
um covet risk by looking at the co2
level
and understanding what the ventilation
is in a room that way and understand
therefore what your
you know what your risk of having covid
kicking around in a little room like
that
to things like um detecting electrical
fields
you know just walking around and being
able to feel electrical fields the
electromagnetic bubble around
adapters and stuff like that um to
uh magnetically wondering um oh sorry go
ahead
magnetic field would help you with a
sense of direction right compass built
in
that's right that's right and in fact in
fact some colleagues of mine
um did that some years ago this um
belt that just buzzes in the direction
of magnetic north
and so people would wear this and they
were always oriented to where
north was and there are a couple of
interesting things that came out of this
one is that
people wore it for a few weeks and then
when they took it off
they retained a better sense of where
north was and i'm very interested in
these kinds of things because
what that implies is that we already
have a little bit of magnetoreception
like many other animals who do have it
humans probably have a little bit of it
but it needs sort of this confirming
external signal
to really boost that up and make you you
know be able to read that signal
so anyway that was one thing is that
people remained much better at it after
they took it off but the other thing
that came out of this paper that was
written about it was that
people would try to explain what it was
like to
know where north was and they would try
to explain this to the people who wrote
the paper and they
didn't quite always get it but the
different participants could
could talk with each other wow and get
it really well
and so this comes back to this issue
that you need to experience something in
order to have
a shared language around and say yeah
isn't it just like
that even though there was no special
purpose vocabulary
for that uh sensory modality they they
were able to
come up with ways of expressing what
they felt to each other
exactly right and yeah you know and this
is so interesting
to me about about what language is and
what vocabulary is it's
all about just shared concepts or at
least concepts we think are shared
like i just assume that you see the red
the way i see red
maybe we do not but if we use that word
we can transact and negotiate in the
outside world
so um yeah but it just becomes weirder
when it's something that's even more
rare and you have to invent a new kind
of word for it
and you mentioned glucose which brings
up something probably people don't even
think about or at least it's not the
first thing that comes to mind when you
ask about new sensory modalities which
is
interior sensing right like keeping
track of the various levels of our blood
sugar blood pressure or whatever uh
is something that is probably easier
than various other things we could try
to imagine
yeah exactly right and and all you need
is whatever kind of sensors already
exist
and of course people are building these
things at a blinding pace
and then we just we take that data and
feed it into the wristband so you feel
this is these
you know spatiotemporal patterns of
vibration um
yeah exactly and the question is what is
that like when you can
have a deeper window into yourself
whether
so we've done this for example with eeg
where you're wearing a little one of
these portable headsets
and you are feeling you know your alpha
waves your gamma
or your delta you're feeling what's
going on with you um
but yeah as we get more and more
sophisticated with this stuff we've done
by the way actually i'll mention
something interesting we've done this
with uh smart watches where
you can feel things like your heart rate
your heart rate variability your
galvanic skin response which is a
measure of your stress and stuff like
that
so all of these things you can feel from
what the watch is measuring but what we
did then is
let's say we switch the bands so
i am feeling your physiology and you're
feeling mine
and the question is what is that
experience like when you're really
tapped into what someone else is feeling
and so
our our first shot at this was to do
this with spouses
um just to see what is that like if you
you know
let's say you're traveling across the
nation and and your wife calls and says
wow sean you feel really stressed out
are you doing okay
and so on um so we don't yet know
whether this is an aid or a hindrance to
marriage
but uh it's something that we're just
interested in about what if you can not
only be tapped into your own body but
someone else's
some things people were not meant to
know david i'm not quite sure this is a
road you want to walk down but but okay
i think we can
we can sort of imagine uh the vistas
here of possibility but
what i like about it is that everything
you described so far
um is pretty realistic on a on a
reasonable time scale like these are
things that are happening and the
technology is changing rapidly
yeah exactly i mean all everything that
i've described so far is not what's
going to happen in a few years but it's
what we've already done in the lab
yeah but okay so now we're near the end
of the podcast so let's uh
let our hair down and uh imagine what
will happen as time goes on i mean we
know that elon musk
has a company neural link that is aiming
toward
a sort of uh ian banks ask neural lace
but uh and i'm sure there's a long time
to go before we have something like that
but
what are the prospects for you know
putting well whether it's through
implants or anything else
directly reading what is going on in our
brain and sharing that
data back and forth across uh the rest
of the world
yeah i mean that's clearly where things
are going it's going to be actually a
long while before we get there we are
still in 2020 stuck with
you know fmri functional magnetic
resonance imaging is our best way of
imaging the brain and the fact is it's a
really crude technology it's not so
great
yeah it's slow it's got poor spatial
resolution but it's the best we've got
so what what musk is doing by the way is
in a sense no different from what we
have been doing for a long time which is
dipping electrodes into the brain
what he's doing is making that a much
tighter nicer process where you're
essentially sewing a little string of
electrodes
into the brain and avoiding blood
vessels and so on so he's making it
better and
it'll be wireless but that said
um where i can see this is going to
really
pay off in the world of neurosciences
and is in clinical neuroscience so
people with
parkinson's or epilepsy or various other
disorder depression other things
this might make sense for them to get
these electrodes in their brain that not
only read but can also write
uh what's happening with the neural
activity um
but part of the sort of idea
the mythology about neural link is hey
everyone will get this so we can
interface with our cell phones faster or
something like that but the fact is
no one's going to go in for an open head
surgery just so you can text faster than
your thumb
can go so uh it's going to be a long
long time possibly until after we're
dead before people are actually doing
this but i will say this is the
direction neuroscience has been going is
how do we get find or find a resolution
on being able to read and write
i have a suspicion that in 30 years
we'll look back at an idea like neural
link
and think okay it wasn't actually the
right approach because
i have a suspicion that we'll be able to
do things from the inside as
in we in you know we do molecularly
precise
three-dimensional printing at the atomic
level we build nano-robots
you can fit you know 100 billion of
these in a
little capsule you swallow the capsule
they swim around your bloodstream
impregnate all the neurons in your head
and then they
send out signals you can use a mesh
network that would
allow these to you know all their
signals get compiled on a little helmet
on the outside
and you might be able to read everything
going on in the brain that way
without ever having to open the armored
bunker plating of the skull
well okay i think we need to um uh
expound on this a little bit more
because
that is exactly what i was wondering you
know yes i i agree with you that most
people
maybe black mirror episodes are a
different thing but most people will be
reluctant to let people
take a drill to their skull to put
something inside but is that
really the obstacle here or can we
get around that in clever ways or are
there other obstacles with just reading
the
uh synapses at all like is it we have
some sense of what the biggest barriers
are
to overcoming that that
gap between the brain and the outside
world oh i mean the the list of barriers
is enormous but the very first thing
would be
just understanding the spiking code
of the 86 million neurons or we don't
actually even know what
subset you would need to measure to get
a pretty good picture of what's going on
so let's just imagine you have to
measure from all 86 billion
um that's challenge number one so if you
had
a little nano robot in each neuron in
your head that's sending out signals
saying oh you just spiked you just
spiked
that's a good start but the synapse is
what's going on at the connections
between these which is you know
another you know 10 000 times more
synapses than neurons
knowing what's going on there might end
up being very useful but on top of that
it's not just the wiring diagram
i mentioned earlier that the shapes of
neurons are changing all the time and
the
um the degree to which a neuron is ready
to pop
off versus really hard to make pop off
and so on
all these things all the way down to
this other thing i mentioned which is
the the epigenome and how you
change the conformation of the
chromosomes so that
certain genes are expressing more than
others you might actually need all that
information and we don't know we don't
know the answer to which of that is oh
that you could skip
that and still get a pretty good read of
the brain um
but it is possible that even though
we're looking at neurons mostly
we're only doing that because that's all
our technology can give us so we're like
the drunk looking for our keys under
this
street light just because that's the
only place we can see but it might
be much worse than that is the other
direction of information flow
easier is it easier to send information
to the brain than to get it out like
if i just wanted to read wikipedia
without touching anything just just by
the
power of my mind is that something that
is uh more realistic
well i mean in a sense that's what your
terrific eyeballs are doing you look at
wikipedia you're
translating all these symbols on the fly
and getting an enormous amount of
information in your brain that way so i
don't know that you'd actually
need to do much more than that for
wikipedia what we're doing at neosensory
is
passing information streams just by this
wearable on your wrist and that's
a super useful way to pass information
in and yes much simpler so
as far as getting information in there
goes i've put all my chips on doing
inexpensive non-invasive ways of
streaming information to the brain
getting it out is the is the hard part i
see okay very
good well we'll er i presume that you
know
there's uncountable number of projects
going on both in laboratories
uh in academia and in startups et cetera
trying to do all sorts of these things
because at least at least it seems
like there's both a utopian far off goal
of everyone having telepathy and being
able to record all their memories in
in ram or something like that but also
little steps along the way that are
individually useful
yeah i think so i i actually am not sure
that anybody views it as a utopian goal
though to be able to
read and write everything and have your
memories on a stick because there's some
sense in which what's going on in the
skull
is an inner sanctum that most people
probably feel should be private
because you have so many thoughts
flitting around your brain and
the way that interacts with this higher
level of our social lives
uh they don't they don't always go
together right um
you have thoughts move to your head that
you would never want other people to be
able to read
or or know that you thought something
um but and yet there is social media and
instagram
maybe the new generation is perfectly
happy with everyone knowing all their
thoughts
that's you know what i doubt it but
that's very interesting i should
interview some young kids who spend
their lives on twitter to ask
but you know even still on twitter of
course they're carefully crafting and
rewriting and deleting their tweets that
are meant to look spontaneous
and represents that's yeah thing that
we're trying to look a certain way for
people um and i don't i don't think
that anybody i would interview but i'm
happy to be proved wrong but i don't
think anybody would actually say yep
open up the whole thing i'm an open book
just read the thoughts flitting through
my head so i
i suspect that what we're going to get
is better and better
really wonderful clinical tools to be
able to help people
with all kinds of disorders um
but when it comes to things like actual
mind reading that's probably going to
face real ethical barriers
for as long as i can imagine i think if
you ask people 50 years ago whether
there be
tv shows that basically just put a bunch
of cameras in someone's house
and broadcast it they would be aghast at
this terrible
invasion of privacy and yet there's a
lot of such tv shows these days
yeah absolutely and
anybody anybody with any brains doesn't
make
guesses about what the future is going
to look like because it's so hard to
to see where these things go but all i
can tell you is
the society that i know now is just not
going to be up for that so it's gonna
have to be a real shift
well we're nearing the end of the
podcast and i don't want to let you get
away
without uh explaining to the audience
what it was
that first let me be aware of your work
because
uh this was ten years ago when i was
organizing a conference on time
uh and the nature of time i wrote wrote
this book from eternity to here and of
course
one of your in my mind anyway one of
your most famous
experiments has to do with how we
perceive time
in uh situations of great anxiety or or
excitement and so forth
and probably there are people here who
don't know about that experiment so
maybe
could you explain that to us and i don't
know whether or not it links into what
we've been already talking about
yeah i mean the that experiment was just
i was fascinated by this issue of
whether time
slows down when you're in fear for your
life when i was a kid i fell off of the
roof and it seemed to take a long time
to hit the ground but once i got to high
school physics i found that it took
something like you know 0.6 seconds and
i couldn't understand
how it seemed to take such a long time
and then as i grew up and i became a
neuroscientist i
collected all kinds of stories from
people who had been in car accidents and
things like that and they described the
scene as though we're in slow motion
so what was interesting to me is there
did not exist
anything in the literature there was no
study on whether this was true or not
what that would mean to sort of
see at a faster rate you know taking all
this information faster rate or
on the other hand maybe you just lay
down memories more densely and
you think it took a longer time so
anyway i did the only experiment which
to my knowledge still the only
experiment that's ever been done on this
which is
i dropped people from 150 foot tall
tower in free fall going backwards and
they're caught in a net below going 70
miles an hour
and it's absolutely terrifying i did it
myself three times
um and it's just so scary falling
backwards and near eventually continent
what i did is i built this device that
flashed information at people at a
certain rate
so that i could see whether during the
fall
they were able to take in information
faster in other words was their frame
rate
actually different where they were
seeing the world in slow motion
i'm skipping some of the technical
details here if i was interested you
could look up
our papers on this but what we found
as far as munchline goes is that people
thought the event took a much longer
time than it did and yet
nobody was actually able to see in slow
motion as in literally see
like neo in the matrix instead we were
able to demonstrate that it's
all a trick of memory when you're in a
fearful situation
you're laying down dense memories and so
when you read that back out even just in
the next moment you say what just
happened what just happened
it seems like you've got so much memory
and just
you know in a bayesian manner if you
read that much memory you assume that
must
translate to a longer time scale
and so everything is about how much
footage you can draw on
um yeah and this does feed back into
what you were saying earlier about the
sort of
different time scales going on in
different processes in the brain
exactly right and when something really
scary and life threatening is happening
that's when that's when you say hey i'm
going to write this down i'm not going
to write this just in sort of
la dee da working memory i'm going to
burn this into the circuitry because
this matters
and so this also at least i don't want
to say explains but speaks to the fact
that when we're in
lockdown and not able to do anything
different from day to day
time seems to move really really slowly
from moment to moment but in retrospect
once all this is over it will seem to
have not lasted that long
exactly right and that's the experience
all of us have had is
it's just unbelievable to me that this
is october of 2020 already it's crazy
um and it's because even though this
whole coveted time has been full of
various sorts of stressors for people
most of us are trapped in the same four
walls and we're very location
sensitive for our memories and so when
you're the same four walls it's really
hard to distinguish
one memory from another and so when i
think okay
how much time has it been since you know
since we shut down in uh
february or something and it's it's very
difficult to draw on
clear footage it's not like oh yeah this
happened then that happened then that
happened
instead just a big blurred mish of all
the
experiences that i've had at home so
it's very difficult to estimate how much
time has passed
i was almost just about to say that uh
once we all get uploaded
into the matrix that we won't we don't
need to worry about these pandemics
anymore but then i remember there are
such a thing as computer viruses
probably be much much worse right like
probably the threats to us
will be enormously greater if we're just
in silico rather than uh
in the physical world well that's right
although as you know
we might already be there i've heard
that somebody
did a podcast on that with nick bostrom
too so okay well
you've given us a lot of things to think
about um uh the book is called
live wired live wired and uh yeah good
luck with
developing these technologies i really
am fascinated by how this is going you
know it's uh
the the brain is complicated as i
started off saying but we're learning a
lot about it it's gonna change the world
when we really figure things out
great great and if any listeners want to
join our next developer contest
uh we're going to announce it soon on
neosensory.com
so think of what kind of sense you would
want what kind of universe you would
want to
experience and then figure out how to
program it with us
i like that all right david eagleman
thanks so much for being on the mind
cape podcast
great thanks so much sean
[Music]
you